oggi andremo a testare 4 gadget per cani
binago girando su amazon
volevo cercare qualcosa per nardi non so
se il suo 15 14 gadgets super divertente
che non vedo l'ora di testare la foto
ora di vedere quale piacerà di più per
lì sembra sbagliato le crocchette voleva
fermarla perché può ridere più forse un
bel mi piace se volete vedere la seconda
parte in cui compro altri gadget per
cani e poi alla fine video diverse
scriverli come tipo di gadget che vi è
piaciuto di più avremmo che il numero
uno
allora questo gadget è una specie di
giochino interattivo in cui il cane deve
riuscire a prendere le crocchette e c'è
una specie di puzzle meccanismo per ogni
punto del giochino andiamo ad aprirlo
vediamo un po come berlino mi sembrasse
interessato giochiamo le rocchette
ma allora proviamo un po
ecco qua il gas è abbastanza grande e
devo dire che le crocchette e un
cromatismo allora qua deve riuscire ad
aprire così con la stampa per prendere
la coppietta si è qua che qua invece qua
deve spostare i cerchietti per prendere
le crocchette e berlino si riuscirà
proviamo subito mettiamo le forchette e
vedrete come impazzisce adesso secondo
me sono mangiatutto aspetta c'è
qualcos'altro quelle cercate allora ci
sono due colonnine da mettere in questi
centrali quindi qua per prendere le
crocchette noi le riempiremo questi e
lui dovrà buttarli giù dovrà prendere in
bocca immagino ma ginesio togliere le
crocchette se la super divertente questo
gioco non vedo l'ora di vedere se miglio
riesce a risolvere tutto il passo allora
stavamo pensando che è meglio tenere
questo per l'ultimo perché se ora
iniziamo le crocchette a merlino si
agita e non sarà più buono e calmo come
vorrà solo le crocchette questo lo
rivedrete alla fine non vi preoccupate
poi facciamo vedere possiamo secondo
gadget
secondo gadget allora questo gadget e un
po particolare ma è super utile se
funziona e un nostro momento perché
[Risate]
un reato che ti aiuta tutto allora e
vediamo se riuscite a capirlo sopportato
ecco allora è un fruitore di zante
praticamente ogni volta che il cane
rientro in casa che aleggiava supersport
perché ha scavato qualche buca è stato
chissà dov'è amarli non piace tanto
scavare le buio e poi filare appunto la
zampa del cane una alla volta
qua e dovrebbe appunto pulirla allora
queste non sono rigide quindi non far
male al cane ma sono di como di silicon
molto morbido e mostrano la sensazione
infilando la mano dentro perché ci sono
tanti di questi cosima non è scomodo e
note la male la mia paura è veramente
morti avesse fatto male assolutamente
non l'avremo testate berlino del grande
dettaglio
volevo capire ora qua non c'è scritto
assolutamente niente manoscritti capisce
ha voluto rubare la gente non so se
bisogna mettere dell'acqua dentro ma non
penso proviamo comunque bene ma zamba
gamba zoppa
gli avevo insegnato solo che ora forse
si sente un po disagio davanti alla
videocamera narrativa già gamba merlino
zampa lo più soluzione pausa luciano 6
prova a prendermi la io infiliamo
l'acqua
allora lui rimane tranquillo più bravo
di stirling ora glielo tolgo ok non mi
sembra che si siano solo un po di temi
non mi sembra sporcizia dentro siamo dal
bravo bravo bravo bravo problemi l'ha
trattata bravo bravo bravo
ok non c'è molta sporcizia però anche
perché non sono sporchissime le sue
tante adesso sono contenta che non gli
dà fastidio insomma non tira via la
zampa unipa paura quindi potrebbe
funzionare per quando rientra in casa
con le zampe pieni di terra
dovremmo trovare il sistema perché lui
di solito lui contempo in casa arrivati
pochissimi in plastica rivelati aveva
spedito a vedere adesso ovviamente non
aveva l'età bitter anche perché propria
l'esilità vola quindi noi speriamo avevo
scoperto l'uomo gioco né fallire
scoppiate le valide voto diamo a questo
gadget da 1 a 10
allora secondi il tempo di veramente
utile se funziona dobbiamo sperimentarlo
meglio quindi gli darei un iniziato in
mezzo si sa che gli darei un 7 perché
comunque lui si fa a mettere le zampe
dentro per viene fatto comunque bene che
morbido qua lo testeremo ancora per
quando mi arriva una le toghe sporche
sporche e li possono sapere se è utile
insomma ma mi sembra abbastanza inutile
prossimo gaza per questo siamo super
guide di provarlo perché abbiamo anche
visto un sacco di video o pubblicità e
siamo stati messi tavano questa specie
di guanti con delle punte di gomma e
quando spazzoli il cane togni via tutti
beni superflui vino frati questo
pelosone
e vero che fa perdere un sacco di guanti
poi se siete resta comunque vi lascio il
link descrizione allora spero che a
berlino non dia fastidio sono comunque
morbide anche queste punte e robert e li
faccio un bel massaggio proviamo un
bacio più preoccupato per un po lo
prendono
allora cari katia come sa che rischia un
buchino problema che si sta tutta
gennaio come vediamo quanti temi toglie
perché un successo può allora berlino si
viaggia da solo tasse non gli dà
fastidio perché sennò sarebbe scappato
però non capisco che fa una sensazione
strana forse è vero però prendo un sacco
di bari bene allora non so se si vede ma
piano piano si sta rimettendo di peli
aiutare gare sono in quanto tranquillo
buono che ne toglie un bel po e in più
nel frattempo lo accarezziamo vediamo
allora io mi sembra tranquillo adesso
non mi sembra finire a fastidio si
stanno rilassando velo che si sta
rilassando quindi non gli dà fastidio
meno male ugo anch'io assurdo bene
sì sì dove ti dia una bella nella
funzione con la zona con questi duranti
sita in cui lo abbiamo visto raccoglie e
massiva tantissimo ma naturalmente non
si può essere anche lui non ne stia
perdendo tantissimi perché comunque sono
forti sui piedi a un rinculo non so se
riuscite a vedere perché sono chiari che
sa tutto il merlino però sono contenta
comunque cartoccio costanzo mi chiamo
toglierli dal quanto è facile come un
pubblicità no non penso
bisogna toglierli un po un po per volta
nella pubblicità facevano così 3 nel
sito gli avanotti atm ma non solo
bisogna avere un po più di pazienza è
solo giorni piano piano riuscito a
vedere quanti per i abbiamo tolto che ci
sta controllando berlino questo è il
rito impegni presentarlo e dobbiamo
testarlo in confronto con una spazzola
normale imbrogli più tailing 00 è vero
che godiamo questo caso è molto direi
anche otto e mezzo il motto è se sono un
po pubblica mondiali mi vedrei un 8
poiché botte lì da tempo vive tema nuoto
e il traffico gadget
grazie per me questo lungo più curiose
persone a cui piacciono i video perché
questa è una pettorina un po speciale
poi vi faccio vedere che lui e spero che
sia facile da bucare ma mette un merlino
e tranquillo non gli dà fastidio perché
l'abbiamo messo abbastanza larga ma vi
starete chiedendo ma a che cosa serve
questa pettorina così strade di pechino
tanti la crisi lo sta chiedendo si sta
guardando all'insieme del video che vi
stanno mettendo quello che sono comunque
con questo nuovo vestitini e ne vanno in
giro a farmi notare dalle altre
cagnolini permette oggi pratica si mette
uno di questi qua sopra o poco meno euro
e quindi anche sodo serve quindi questa
piccolina server attaccare una
videocamera allora questa è la
confezione perché se l'abbiamo giu
comunque una videocamera piccolino
ovviamente altrimenti difesa troppo
potete riprendere ad esempio se la state
vostro cane da solo a casa e volete
vedere cosa fa e infatti stiamo pensando
per video a riguardo la sete un bel mi
piace se volete vederlo
ovviamente non va tenuta per troppo
tempo perché li può dare fa spesso gli
ocra e alla camera sopra che pu pesarli
sia i vari lazio appunto va tenuta per
poco tempo che è fatta molto bene questa
lettori ne contengono anche al mondo lui
l'unica cosa che l'abbiamo messa male
dobbiamo poi farli passare le zampe
essi infatti che sono monetaria poi
quando lottare moglie lo metteremo
dovevamo farli passare le zampe qua
pensavo che doveva farle passare va
dentro invece non dovevamo fargliene
passare papato l'abbiamo appunto
sistemata così dovrebbe stare meglio
dobbiamo stringere un pochino ovviamente
perché un po larga ma per ora solo per
farvi vedere come lui gli dà fastidio è
molto tranquillo
amore mio voto diamo questo cazzo ma
secondo me merita un bel 9 lei non
vedere beckham eravamo non attaccando la
puntata qui quindi ecco montale che può
filmare dalla sua testa dove c'è un
vecchietto in poi
eppure può essere montata anche sotto al
contrario per far vedere al teatro
certi suoi regionali dove in tanti mi
chiedete sempre mi commetti ma che razza
è merlino scrivi che rotaie merlino
allora berlino è un meticcio lo abbiamo
adottato al canile se non avete visto il
video vi lascio il link alla fine di
questo video nelle quattro caselline
comunque lo so che è un tesoro ed è
veramente bellissimo ma sono di parte
perché il mio padrino ovviamente per
ogni padrone il cambio di aver sempre
più bello del mondo
comunque vi dico che al canile ci sono
tantissimi cani stupendi e dolcissimi
quindi non pensate che dovete per forza
comprare un cane perché al canile ce ne
sono tantissimi e poi essere il loro
sogno più grande è trovare una famiglia
che li adotti
e sono lì appunto soli che aspettano ci
sono veramente tantissimi cani al canile
che vogliono soltanto dare e ricevere
amore quindi perché non fare un
viaggetto al canile questo weekend anche
solo ad andare a vederli magari passare
un po di tempo con loro ci siamo
arrivati all'ultimo gadget che è quello
che abbiamo visto all'inizio ti portiamo
l'intelligenza di zanchetta
vediamo se devo prendere tutte le
cassette dal fatto di scena eccolo qua
pronto vediamo quanti di s
a tirare un po il primo che c'è capito
vediamo se riuscendo prendevi 11 che
queste guide vi piega o non corrono
cengio nel meridione
secondo asportato di schietta facilmente
si rigetta che tutti viviamo
ok vediamo un po allora da bossoli così
veniamo presi anche dal cerchietto sito
prendere anche l'altro dal sembra
berlino ora mancano le tue cortine el
altro osso gente per liga penso che le
due colonnine siano un po complicate o
difficile per noi giocando di staccare 4
di questo me lo mangio cercando di
staccare un motore ma come arriva al
tavolo dai berlinesi sono gli altri
[Musica]
partiti
bravo aspetto che aiuto continuo
dall'altro lato che forse più facile per
terra dai dai berlino bravo bravo bravo
bravo chiaro dovrebbe tirar la guardano
guarda che lo stiamo sbavando tutti fra
bruno dire impegnato tanto gli piace
adesso me lo mangio tutto era tutto
al 32 bene così perché quello sì ora si
ricorda che anche l'altra colonnina deve
tirar la vediamo ora l'ultimo la
colonnina che bravo adesso io me lo
mangio tutto è bravo bravo penso che
sarebbe riuscito comunque in poco tempo
a prendere tutte le croci piantate vetro
cantillo sempre pronto ad ha continuato
a cercarli a sbavare tutto ovviamente
quando già fa mica sto gioco dove che
porta sempre essere presenti calcio
polis in voi una delle colonnine e
adesso la star lo dichiara marco parolo
che forse la mangi mamma divertente
perché potete far divertire il vostro
cane e potete farlo anche ragionare un
pochino
così si guadagnerà alle sue crowe che
temiamo di anche divertente per vedere
anche divertente per lui dire è stato
spento via a cercare di smontare tutto
abbiamo fatto bene a tenerlo per ultimo
sarebbe stato impossibile togliere
allora questo gadget e ti do un bel 10
anche perché super divertente ed è utile
per far divertire il canone perché farlo
diventare intelligente anche se in
questo caso non si lasciò lasciano via
via ecco allora come vicario che vince
secondo te va bene allora la pettorina
ha delle grandissime potenzialità perché
secondo me sarà molto divertente mettere
dell'affare un video con la camera sulle
spalle di berlino però questo secondo me
è quello che mi è piaciuto di più a lui
si è anche secondo me vince questo di
calcio perché non vedo super divertito
il tutto per contenta di vedere
divertente prese da questo gioca un
pranzo che lo saremo qui fino al piano
francia nella seconda parte mi
raccomando da state un bel mi piace a 10
mila mi piace
andremo a fare la seconda parte andrò a
cercare altri che oggi riganti si voi
altri tipi di gas che conoscete per cane
che volete che testiamo che magari è
stato utilizzando anche voi e che vi
sentite di consigliarci ora vi lasciamo
qua l'altro castellini su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video caso
quella che preferite leporelli tione
ciao
ecco perché
[Musica]